we really went for like the throat of
the industry when we first came out at
our price point so there was a really
quick adoption and that's what's allowed
us to grow so quickly compared to the
rest of the space
i'm levi conlow the co-founder and ceo
for electric ebikes a direct consumer
electric bike company based out of
phoenix arizona
we came into this space because my old
man wanted an electric bike during
college i had been selling electric
skateboards out of my dorm room and then
i had graduated college with my buddy
robbie and we wanted to work on a
business together and my old man came to
us and said please work on an electric
bike i need you to do that at that time
the average price of an electric bike
was around three thousand dollars and
we knew we could do it for a much more
affordable price and so we go we start
doing the research and we start the
sourcing and went back to the old man
and said great news man it's not gonna
cost three thousand it's gonna cost
about forty thousand dollars and so he
gave us a loan for that uh first batch
of bikes and it was an absolute disaster
failed so bad lost his money really
potentially screwed up his retirement
and we came back to him after the
feedback of why people didn't like that
first you know style bike and everything
i asked my dad how would you like to
lose 10 000 more dollars and at that
point he knew i had already screwed up
his retirement so he gave us uh the
extra 10 and then that's what designed
the new bike and then that new bike
almost instantly became a massive
success we've only been doing it for
about two and a half years but it's the
fastest growing electric bike company in
the us and we've got over a hundred
thousand bikes sold
in the us so far
[Music]
the reality is robbie and i are 25 years
old have the best job in the world
selling a ton of electric bikes so five
years out
i just want to keep selling more bikes
right i'm extremely bullish and
optimistic
on this market and it's just we just
want to keep the good times rolling and
just keep riding this journey as long as
we can